you said that there are three categories
of people who vote Republican and uh
that Trump introduced the fourth one
well can you go through
the four categories sure so you've got
like your pro-business low tax
Republicans these are mostly people like
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney has a bit of the
social conservatism as well he's Mormon
and that's there but Mitt Romney
primarily particularly as a Northeast
sort of Republican I mean I know Utah
but governor of Massachusetts he is like
a low tax pro-business type guy you've
got your libertarian type Republicans
who are primarily about uh freedom and
liberty often they are actually more
socially liberal where they go I don't
care about gay marriage liberal you know
I don't care so much about abortion
um and that
overlapped a little bit with the Tea
Party Movement in 2010 although tea
party did have a religious component but
sort of like the libertarian
freedom-minded folks and then the
religious conservatives people that
support Canada it's like Josh Hawley or
uh Ted Cruz Etc where their big thing
are social issues often they actually
want uh Christianity being civil
government they don't want separation of
church and state those are traditionally
the three Republican groups the one that
Trump introduced was people who just
didn't really pay attention to politics
but either followed celebrity or had
grievances that they didn't yet have a
scapegoat for
um and were sort of right-leaning
culturally even though they didn't
attribute that to republicanism
and Trump was able to bring them into
politics often for the first time as
voters they could be part of any of
those three groups if they get more into
politics or kind of be their own thing
but they're more kind of like Cult of
Personality I'm here for Trump types did
it have to do anything about the culture
wars and the identity politics all that
kind of stuff
yeah I mean so in 2016 when Trump
mobilized them those weren't really
issues the way they are now so I think
at the time at that time it certainly
was not a factor what was the mobilizing
issue I know it was it just anti-hillary
in 2016. there he did a good job on
anti-hillary but a lot of it was
identifying real economic problems wage
depression lack of jobs in parts of the
country you know Ohio and Indiana Trump
rightly identified like we have an issue
here we don't have enough
entrepreneurship Etc
um but there was also a lot of
scapegoating that was you know China and
people coming through the U.S Mexico
border were popular scapegoats for a lot
of those problems this gets us kind of
to populism
populism is a rhetoric and populism as a
rhetoric doesn't necessarily come with
particular policies you can be
a populist uh a user of populist
rhetoric and proposed solutions that
would be more aligned with Bernie or
Tucker Carlson
populists will often identify the plight
of the middle class
the difference would be Bernie will say
we've got to put some restrictions on
how much uh billionaires can make and
we've got to reinvest in these social
programs Tucker will say BLM taking your
house and a brown person from Mexico
taking your job are what we need to deal
with
so the the populist rhetoric can lend it
lend itself to very different policy and
Trump used that very effectively in
2016. why do you think Hillary Clinton
was
hated as intense as she was by a certain
percent of the population it feels like
um that's the first election eyewitness
where there's a lot of hate
maybe I'm misremembered I don't remember
Obama
um
I don't remember the degree of hate
there was a conspiracy theories that he
wasn't born in this country but I don't
remember hate towards Obama record death
threats under Obama more than any
previous president right towards who
towards him towards him yeah do you mean
more hate between voters or between
voters between voters but like
that's I guess what I was speaking to
but that hate was directed towards
um The Narrative the thread that
connected all of that in 2016 was
Hillary Clinton
few different things
um and I'm not ranking these these are
just all things that come to mind one is
Hillary Clinton
had been around in the political space
for a long time from her time as first
lady through a senator Secretary of
State Etc so I think that there was
enough time for different groups to
develop an antipathy towards her for
different reasons so time
um secondly
Trump's branding of her as crooked
was very effective yeah where there were
so many people demanding that she be
imprisoned if you ask them what is the
crime they don't know but she should
definitely be locked up that became a
very big thing
the email story as it were and uh James
Comey doing a second public event about
that investigation even though there
wasn't any actual news about it just
doing a second event about it at the
last minute I think hurt her and also
generated some hate and I don't find
Hillary Clinton to be particularly
likable although I voted for her I
thought she was the better candidate and
I think that there are others who also
didn't find her particularly likable
that those are a lot of impediments to
becoming president I was trying to
understand why there's so many
conspiracy theories about Clinton's in
general Bill Clinton and Hillary Clinton
and I
maybe I'm not researched well enough
the of the why of it uh the Y of it
actually the extent of the conspiracy
theories the sort of the the conspiracy
theories that they've killed a lot of
people this kind of stuff it's hard for
me to speak to them because I'm aware
that they exist but I'm not an expert in
them because they seem so obviously
baseless to the degree that I've
researched them a little bit and then I
move on and uh you know it's been years
since I've looked at this stuff I know
there's the Seth Rich one and there's
the Clinton Body Count one I think
there's one connected to Epstein if I
recall correctly there's all sorts of
these different ones
um without speaking to any of them
specifically because I'm not the expert
on Clinton conspiracies uh it does seem
as though this stuff for so long has
generated an audience I mean I remember
in the supermarket when Bill Clinton was
President at the checkout seeing the
tabloids and there were stuff about
Hillary birth than alien baby and you
know all the it seems like it's been
titillating to people for a very long
time